이쪽에 1억 2천
은
모르겠습니다
노코멘트 하겠습니다 더 이상
공격당하기 싫습니다
[음악]
제가 오늘은
박효신 님이 한남동에 건물을
매입했다라고 해서 제가 한번 좀
찾아봤습니다네 개인적인 얘기도 한번
좀 더 붙여서
얘기를 좀 해보도록 하겠습니다
우선 좀 기사를 좀 보면 한남동
건물주 됐다 120억
현금 박치기
현금으로 매입했다라는
기사입니다 그리고 돼지가 한 100평
정도 되는 그런 건물이었습니다 그래서
기존에 원래 다세대가 아니라
다가구주택이었어요 지금은 제가 보니까
지금 건물을 아마 멸실한 것 같습니다
신축을 계획하시는 거 같고 그때 아마
이제 현금으로 매입하게 된 거는 주택
상태로는 대출이 좀 안 나와서 그냥
현금으로
매입한 것으로 좀 보여집니다 그리고
토지이용계획을 처음에 보면은 이게
1종 일반주거지역으로 되어 있어요
건폐율
60%의
용적률 150%입니다 일종이 150
2종 2백 3종이 250 이렇게
보시면 될 것 같아요 1종
일반주거지역이구요 만일 1종
전용주거지역이었으면 용적률이 더
낮아요 거의 100% 정도라고 보시면
될 것 같습니다 대지가 지금
100평이잖아요 그랬을 때 위에 층
면적이 150평까지 지울 수 있는
거예요 150%니까
지상부
면적이 150평 그리고 뭐 지하까지
파면은 제가 봤을 때는 한 230평
220평 뭐이 정도 될 것 같습니다
근데 뭐 지하를 덮어 하는 경우 이제
면적이 좀 더 나오겠지만 이거를
120억에 매입했습니다
그러면 대지평당 1억 1억 2천만원
1종 일반주거지역에 1억 2천만원
매입을 했습니다 한남동인데 여기
한강진역 있고 여기 이태원역 카페거리
더 내려와서
라인원 한남 있는
인근에 있어요 그리고 위쪽에는 이제
순천항 대학병원 있고요 이쪽 인근이
상권은 이제 순천향병원 앞쪽이 좀
많이 있고 여기 그 한남동 카페거리
쪽에 있지만 지금 이쪽 위치 같은
경우에는
특별히 상권이 있거나 그렇지는 않아요
그리고 지금 주택가가 많고 지금 여기
보시는 대사관들 좀 밀집되어 있는
그런 지역입니다
본인 살고 있는 집 근처로
매입한 것으로 좀 보여집니다 한남동
투자한다 그러면 일단은 한남동
카페거리
꼼데가르손길 그쪽 내려와서 있는 그쪽
부분이나 아니면 한남더힐 앞에 이쪽이
좀 많이 사고 그 다음에 조금 더
나아가서는 뭐 순천향대학병원 인근
이쪽에 많이 사는데 이쪽 이면에 산
거는
조금
좀 드문 일인 거 같아요
직접 지어서 좀 어떻게 하실지 좀
궁금하긴 한데 아무래도 본인 살고
있는 집 근처라서 이제 좀 매입한
것으로 좀 보여지긴 하는데 그래서 저
개인적인 생각은 120억의
현금이
물론 지금
금리가 높긴 하지만 120억을 이렇게
현금으로 다
낸
부분에 있어서 저는 조금
조금 아쉽다 뭐 이런 생각입니다
그래서 레버리지를 조금 이용해서 뭐
예를 들어서
200억대 건물을 사면 좀 어땠을까
제 개인적인 생각입니다 그리고 내
입을 할 때 한남더힐이나 여기
카페거리 있는 쪽 아니면은
강남구에 있는
조금 도로 잘 접한 그런 건물을 사면
좀 어땠을까 뭐 이런 생각도 좀 들고
여기도 약간 이제 막힌 길이거든요
개인적인 주관적인 관점에서는
뭔가 좀 더 좋은 선택지가 있지
않았을까 뭐 이런 생각도 좀 들고
나중에 이거를 120억에 사오고 나서
신축비가 들겠죠
신축비가 뭐 거의 200평 이상
지으면 거의 뭐 한 2-30억 들겠죠
그러면 나중에 200억 그 이상의
액시스를 해야 되는데
과연 이쪽 여기 안쪽에 뭐 200억
넘게 매각이 될까 뭐 이런
엑시 생각도 조금 하게 됐어요
과연 매각이 될까 뭐 이런 생각도 좀
들긴 하는데
조금 금액대 높은
쪽으로 좀 도전할 수 있지 않았을까
뭐 이런 생각도 좀 들고
그래도 강남구에 좀 괜찮은 지역의
건물도 살 수 있거든요 그래서 뭐
신사나 청담 뭐 노년 역삼 삼성
빌딩을 사면 좀 더 좋지 않았을까 뭐
이런 생각도 좀 들고 아직 뭐 상권이
여기가 아예 없어요 거기다 주택가고
대사관 이쪽이 1억 2천
은
모르겠습니다
노코멘트 하겠습니다 더 이상
공격당하기 싫습니다 제발 박효신
팬분들 전혀 뭐 제 말이 맞다 그게
아니라 그냥 주관적인 생각이니까
어떻게 신축할지 저도 되게 궁금해요
그래서 나중에 이제
신축하고 나서 한번 저도 현장 가서
한번 좀 보도록 하겠습니다 그래서
아마
본인이 직접 쓸 용도로 사지 않았을까
이렇게 조심스럽게 예상을 합니다
아무래도 본인 거주하고 있는 곳이랑
뭐 그렇게 멀지 않은 위치이기 때문에
그래서 오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요 제
그러니까 이런 좀 이런 이슈가 될
만한 그런 빌딩 소재들이 있으면은
계속 저희가 영상을
촬영하도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다
다음에 뵙겠습니다 감사합니다